welcome to the man of Recaps you may
have noticed a lot of these new Star
Wars series are bringing into live
action characters that were introduced
in the animated Clone Wars or Rebels if
you love Star Wars they're both great
and you should watch them but if you
don't have the time I got you covered to
start you off with a super simplified
Star Wars timeline the Galaxy went for
public Empire Republic Empire the Clone
Wars takes place here in between
episodes two and three and remember the
Galaxy was in civil war between the
Republic and the separatist Alliance it
stars our Jedi main characters from the
prequel movies Anakin Skywalker and his
master Obi-Wan Kenobi the Jedi are
Generals in this Ward leading the
Republic forces against the separatist
droid army and remember it's called The
Clone Wars because the Republic troops
are all clones but right at the start
were introduced to a new main character
who wasn't in the movies the young Jedi
Padawan Ahsoka Tano who's been assigned
to Anakin as an apprentice ahsoka's real
fun calls him Sky guy oh don't get
snippy with me Snips and pretty soon
these two are best friends but Anakin's
not the only one who had an apprentice
that wasn't in the movies the separatist
leader Count Dooku is training the
skinny goth assassin asajj Ventress
she's real cool fights with two
lightsabers and eventually Ahsoka does
too because I mean two Sabers are better
than one so the show features all the
big characters from the prequel movies
Yoda Mace Windu Count Dooku General
Grievous but it also sometimes features
some of the background characters that's
why if you ask a Star Wars Super Fan who
their favorite Jedi is they're saying
someone you've never heard of like
placoon Padme Amidala has a pretty big
role as the senator for Naboo and
remember she and Anakin are secretly
married she goes out on diplomatic
missions but diplomacy usually fails and
she has to resort to aggressive
diplomacy and of course there's
Chancellor Palpatine leader of the
Republic but secretly he's leader of the
separatists too as his Sith Alter Ego
Darth Sidious a major new character
introduced in the show is The Lovable
pirate Hondo onaka the Jedi sometimes
work with him on smuggling stuff but
Hondo's always willing to betray him if
he can make a bigger profit but the
separatists can't really be trusted to
pay him so most of the time he's working
for the Republic as a goodish guy but on
the flip side is Bounty Hunter CAD Bane
who has just a really cool hat he's a
bad dude that's a cold-blooded killer
and he's a great fighter he can hang
with these Jedi speaking about the
hunters there's young Boba Fett who's
formed his own little Bounty Hunter crew
he tries to get revenge on Mace Windu
who remember killed his father Jango
Fett in Attack of the Clones on andron
we meet a young Sagar era who would go
on to be a somewhat brutal Rebel leader
featured in Rogue one and of course some
of the main characters in The Clone Wars
are the clone troopers themselves yeah
they may all be genetically identical
but they all have their own
personalities the main one we follow is
Captain Rex who's in charge of Anakin's
division the 501st they're all born with
numbers but they get nicknames like Echo
for repeats things or sometimes just
fives whose number is all fives the main
theme of The Clone Wars is that these
Troopers aren't Expendable machines like
droids they're real people this comes to
a head when the 501st is Lent out to the
Jedi General Krell who treats them like
they are disposable sends them into
suicide missions it's an intense
military dilemma do you trust your
commanding officer sees the big picture
or do you have to disobey orders when
they're clearly incompetent but in the
end they realize he's used the cover of
Darkness to have the Clones fight
themselves yes he's actively turned to
the dark side betrayed the Republic to
join the separatists so the Clones put
him down but the most important Arc
begins with asajj Ventress remember the
Sith have a rule of two one Mass after
one Apprentice because if The Apprentice
takes an apprentice they can team up and
overthrow the master so Dooku tries to
have Ventress killed but she escapes and
goes back to her home planet ruled by
the night mother a powerful witch she
helps to get revenge on Dooku by buffing
up one of the males of their species
this absolute Beast Savage oppress he
inventors team up to go kill Dooku but
it doesn't work Dooku's too strong so
Ventress goes off to find new meaning in
her life she briefly joins Boba Fett's
group of bounty hunters but the night
mother has a new plan for Revenge with
the strongest of their species yes it's
Darth Maul a super cool villain that was
underused in the movies because he died
at the end of episode 1 when Obi-Wan
Kenobi cut him in half but turns out
he's a hard guy to kill he survived with
just the top half of his body grafted
onto spider Droid legs the night mother
hooks him up with a new pair of legs and
yes it's happening Darth Maul is back
his primary goal is Revenge on Obi-Wan
Kenobi he and Savage fight him a bunch
but they can't beat him so now let's cut
over to the planet of Mandalore yes the
people with the super cool armor that
are an honor-bound Warrior culture but
at the moment mandalors become a
pacifist Planet their current ruler
Dutchess sateen is trying to make them
into a more civil Society but of course
there's some who prefer the old ways and
The Fringe group Death Watch is trying
to take over so Death Watch makes an
alliance with Maul who's a real smart
guy actually he like organizes a whole
coup but now Maul challenges their
leader to single combat to be ruler of
the planet and when you're an
honor-bound Warrior culture that's
allowed now the Death Watch leader
previousla has a super cool black
lightsaber sword the darksaber it was
made by an ancient Mandalorian who was
also a Jedi and by tradition whoever
holds it is the rightful ruler of
Mandalore but now Maul kills this guy
and takes the darksaber for himself and
most death watch is like alright cool
now remember for Jedi romance is
forbidden but if Obi-Wan we're gonna
date anyone it would be sateen so
naturally he goes to Mandalore to
rescuer but it was a trap and Maul kills
her oh now we're crying everywhere now
one of the death watch leaders was the
orange-haired bo Katan who was never
down with the whole Mall thing and
especially not now because sateen was
her sister so she rescues Obi-Wan and
bogutan goes to fight to liberate
Mandalore but it's someone unexpected
who defeats Darth Maul yes it's
Palpatine himself he can't have any
Rivals for Lord of the Sith and so it's
time for an epic lightsaber battle boom
boom Palpatine showing that he's a beast
in the end he kills savagio press but he
leaves them all alive to serve his own
nefarious schemes back on course on
someone has bombed the Jedi Temple and
Anakin and Ahsoka are on the case Ahsoka
is sent to interrogate the suspect but
she's like oh I've been set up and just
then someone's killing her remotely with
the force and unfortunately Ahsoka was
the only one in the room and it sure
kinda looks like she's guilty so
ahsoka's gotta go on the run to clear
her name and her investigations lead her
to none other than Ventress but Ventress
had no part of this she's just working
as a bounty hunter now and she's trying
to be less evil these days so she helps
Ahsoka a little bit but ahsoka's
recaptured before she finds proof and
it's like yo I'm clearly innocent please
let's do an investigation but the war
has clouded the Jedi council's judgment
and even Yoda makes mistakes sometimes
they expel Ahsoka from the Jedi Order
but her master Anakin believes she's
innocent and pretty soon tracks down the
real culprit so the Jedi give her a half
apology Yoda's like or bad that was but
ahsoka's disillusioned with the Jedi now
and it's like honestly screw you guys
she and Anakin had such a close
relationship and it's heartbreaking for
him to let her go but Ahsoka Tano leaves
the Jedi Order in the next major arc a
clone malfunctions he kills his
commanding Jedi yes he executed Order 66
early Vibes takes point on the
investigation and discovers all clones
have a chip in their brain he tries to
uncover this vast conspiracy and is
brought to see the chancellor himself
but of course he is the one behind this
conspiracy so Fox tries to kill him but
now he looks guilty and now they put him
down no fives was the loyalist Trooper
of them all and now the truth dies with
him now let's meet an elite clone Squad
the bad batch because they all have
mutations but that make him pretty
strong they rescue a trooper who was
captured by separatists and turns out it
is our old friend Echo who we thought
was dead when he sacrificed himself a
long time ago but they experimented on
him he's half cyborg now and so he
figures he'll join the bad batch finally
we catch up with Ahsoka Tano who long
story short befriended some good
Smugglers the Martez sisters but she
learns that Maul is leading a crime
syndicate and she gets a visit from Boca
tan who's like he also took over
Mandalore again now unfortunately the
Republic can't really help out but
Anakin Skywalk [__] like yo girl I
got you he lends her Rex and the 501st
who have painted their helmets Orange in
ahsoka's honor so Ahsoka leads the siege
of Mandalore which ends with an epic
lightsaber duel between her and Maul in
the end the good guys win and Boca tan
has liberated Mandalore again but as
we'll find out in Rebels it doesn't last
so as Ahsoka and directs have a touching
moment of friendship after having fought
in battles together all across the
Galaxy the timelines caught up to
Revenge of the Sith and oh it's
happening executor
66. yes all across the Galaxy the clone
troopers are mind controlled into
betraying and killing their Jedi friends
Ahsoka barely manages to escape in fact
she frees Darth Maul to cause a
distraction so he goes off to continue
Shenanigans luckily Ahsoka subdues Rex
and gets that ship out of his brain but
all the other clones cannot be reasoned
with and it's tragic as Ahsoka and Rex
have to fight him they manage to escape
as the cruiser crashes and it's a
heart-wrenching visual as Ahsoka gave
them all a proper burial and so Ahsoka
Tano is one of the few surviving Jedi
who like the others across the Galaxy
leaves her lightsabers behind to go into
hiding the Republic has fallen the
Empire has risen the Clone Wars animated
series comes to an end the only way it
ever could in tragedy now it's time for
Star Wars Rebels which takes place here
during the height of the Empire getting
close to the events of the original
trilogy on the planet of lothal we meet
young orphan Ezra Bridger he's a small
Time Thief who survives by stealing from
the Empire he's basically Aladdin but
today there's another group stealing
from the Empire and they're not just
thieves their Rebels long story short
Ezra joins their crew their leader is
Kanan Jairus who's rocking the ponytail
goatee and he's got a secret he is a
Jedi one of the last survivors of Order
66 but the group's real leader is
Captain Harrison Doula an ace pilot and
team mom there's a young Mandalorian
Sabine Wren who is an artist and
explosives expert then there's Zeb who
is your classic big grumpy alien guy and
last but not least is the team's Droid
Chopper who is a crazy chaotic Mayhem
machine he's the real MVP of this team
because with a paint job the Empire
ignores him and because he makes a habit
of blowing up entire Star Destroyers
he's maybe got the highest kill count in
all of Star Wars so the crew flies
around on their ship the ghost doing
Rebel missions mostly here on the fall
now at first Ezra's main contribution to
the crew is being small enough to crawl
through air nuts but pretty soon he
discovers whoa he can use the force so
Kanan takes him on as a Jedi apprentice
and in general becomes a great father
figure mentor to him pretty soon they
visit the Jedi Temple here on lothal
where Ezra has a Vision Quest gets his
kyber Crystal and wow builds his own
lightsaber and it's a real unique
lightsaber because the hilt is a blaster
which is a nice upgrade from his former
slingshot hunting them down for the
Imperial Security Bureau is Agent kallis
a man with truly epic sideburns but now
that they're Jedi the Empire brings out
the big guns and sends an Inquisitor
yeah they're a group of Darkseid Force
users who have been trained to hunt down
Jedi and their signature weapon are
these unique circular spinny lightsabers
now Kane and Jairus is pretty outmatched
he was only a Padawan during Order 66
but when he thinks Ezra's killed he goes
into beast mode and exploits this guy's
obvious weakness and so in the season 1
finale the grand Inquisitor dies but
this really catches the Empire's
attention and now they bust out the
bigger guns oh snap it's Darth Vader
Kaden and Ezra are way outmatched
through sheer luck they managed to
escape so now lothal is too hot for him
they gotta lay low they meet up with
Hera's Rebel contact fulcrum who turns
out is Ahsoka Tano yeah she's back and
fighting for the rebellion and somewhere
along the line she built herself new
white lightsabers all right super cool
her Rebel self Phoenix Squadron is still
real small but it's trying to grow she
sends ghost crew to recruit an old
friend yes a surviving clone old bearded
Captain Rex we get one off cameos with
some future Rebel leaders like Princess
Leia and Lando Calrissian and there's a
ton of episodes with Hondo onaka a
lovable pirate from the Clone Wars
because Ezra is a bit of a thief himself
these two actually become good friends
eventually Ahsoka takes Ezra and Kane in
on a secret Jedi mission to an ancient
Sith Temple and here Ezra finds a
mysterious old hermit yes it is Darth
Maul he doesn't want to fight because
the emperor is his enemy too and he's a
pretty cool guy Ezra kind of likes him
but soon he betrays them and oh it's
Kanan in the eyes he manipulates Ezra to
use the Sith holocron to activate the
temple which is a big weapon then Mal
will make Ezra his new dark side
apprentice and together they'll
overthrow the emperor and rule the
galaxy but Kane and Jairus isn't gonna
let that happen yes he's been blinded
but he gets lucky and throws Darth Maul
off the cliff but someone noticed when
they activated the temple oh snap it's
Darth Vader and this became an iconic
Vader line I'm not afraid of you then
you will die braver than most but now
Ahsoka Tano arrives and it's time for
the Epic Master Apprentice lightsaber
duel when she cuts open his mask she
gets to see it really is her old friend
and Mentor Anakin in there but at this
point Darth Vader has fully
disassociated I killed Anakin Skywalker
so as Ezra and Kanan deactivate the
temple Ahsoka stays behind to finish off
Vader but when we see Vader walking away
Ahsoka Tano is presumed dead so the
rebels have been searching for a new
home base and of course it's Chopper who
finds one for him he befriends an
imperial Droid ap5 who becomes his sassy
C-3PO to Choppers R2D2 he helps them
find the planet atalan not on Imperial
charts and it's a pretty great base
except for the giant spider monsters now
Kanan Jairus is permanently blind but he
finds a Mystic creature bendu who
teaches him how to see through the force
now Ezra Bridger has buzzed his hair and
built himself a new green lightsaber
he's becoming a real strong Jedi but he
started playing with the sithalacron and
flirting with the dark side but pretty
soon Kanan helps him realize the dark
side is bad but now Maul comes back to
get that holocron and he makes Ezra open
up a Jedi one with it which combined
will answer any question you want and
the question ball most wanted answered
is the location of his old rival Obi-Wan
Kenobi and so it's time for the final
old man Obi-Wan Darth Maul duel but as
soon as it starts it's already over yes
Obi-Wan's been ready for this takes him
out in one blow Samurai style and it is
kind of a sad moment as Obi-Wan just
pity's Maul he never had a chance was
brought to the dark side at a young age
and lived a life of pain and anger so
now we know how Maul's story ends but
this probably isn't the last we'll see
of him because he was still alive during
this whole chunk and turns out Maul
still had the darksaber so now our
mandalorians Sabine Wren claims it
remember Mandalore was liberated by the
Republic at the end of the Clone Wars
but immediately the Republic became the
Empire and so mandalor's been under
Imperial rule so Sabine goes home like
yo mom it's time to liberate Mandalore
did someone say liberate Mandalore yeah
Bo katans obviously in so young Sabine
Wren with the darksaber leads her people
to kick out the Empire but Sabine
doesn't want to stay here and Rule
Mandalore she's gotta go back off with
the rebel friends the ghost crew so she
passes the dark saber to bocatan who has
successfully liberated Mandalore again
but as we'll find out in the Mandalorian
it doesn't last now our Rebels Phoenix
Squadron has been outspighting the
Empire across the Galaxy so now the
Empire brings out the big guns Grand
Admiral thrawn yes the main villain from
the old Star Wars novels before there
were any prequels or sequels the story
is just part of Legends now but thrawn
himself is officially Canon enthron is a
real interesting character very
soft-spoken always calm and collected
most importantly he is a genius
tactician who instantly sees through all
our Rebels tricks every time they escape
this season is because he lets them he's
trying to figure out where the rebel
base is but the rebels have an advantage
a spy on the inside and pretty soon
ghost crew discovers it's their old
enemy agent kallus yeah there was an
episode where kallus and Zeb Crush
landed on a planet had to work together
to survive and kallus turns out is an
honorable dude who now realizes the
Empire is bad but unfortunately thrawn
found out he's the spy and used his
broadcasts to pinpoint the rebel base so
thrawn rolls up in force ready to crush
the Rebellion completely I am not
accepting surrenders at this time but
there's one thing thrawn couldn't have
predicted the old creature bendu who
doesn't appreciate all this fighting on
his Planet so Phoenix Squadron joins the
rest of the Rebellion which is set up
shop on Yavin 4 yeah the planet from a
new hope they're hanging out with Rebel
leader mon mothma their rebellions
reached its final form but our ghost
crew of course was not in a new hope
they go back to their old stomping
grounds lothal to stop thrawn from
building his new improved tie Defenders
now Kanan Jairus makes a big life
decision now it's time to lose the
ponytail although not sure if they
should let the blind guy cut his own
hair now all series long it's been kind
of assumed that Kanan and Hera are in a
romantic relationship but it's never
been mentioned or really shown but
finally it's confirmed there was never
any doubt and the understatedness of
their relationship makes it kind of
beautiful but tragically just then the
mission goes bad and kanan's gotta use
the force to stop the explosion and this
is it there's no other way Kanan Jairus
sacrifices himself to save his family oh
so sad for what is mostly a kid show now
Ezra Bridger has always had a strong
connection to animals specifically the
wildlife of lothal like the super cute
loaf cats but now the mysterious loath
wolves show up who have a Mystic
connection to the force they show Ezra
the secret back door to the Jedi Temple
which is a Trippy weird space with
doorways to different points in space
and time Ezra finds when that leads to
the Ahsoka Vader duel and Justice
Vader's about to win wow he joints her
out of there she's like wow man thanks
didn't know the force could time travel
and she helps him understand that he
can't save Kanan the same way because it
would create a Time Paradox in fact she
goes back to the time she came from to I
guess lay low for a few years to not
upset the timeline so now it's time to
liberate lothal our Rebels are vastly
outnumbered but Ezra gets reinforcements
from the loath wolves oh yeah and these
things are beasts unfortunately just
then thrawn comes back and he is
accepting surrenders this time and
Ezra's brought in for a Skype call with
Emperor Palpatine himself he really
wants that Jedi Temple time travel so
he's brought a piece of it here and
tries to tempt Ezra into opening it by
showing him visions of his parents but
Ezra's come to terms with their loss and
so he destroys the temple so Palpatine
can't get it of course there's still
thrawn to deal with but Ezra had a
secret plan that even thrawn couldn't
have predicted in a pretty early episode
we met a real crazy animal the pergil
that are these whale squid things that
live in space and can travel through
light speed Ezra naturally formed a bond
with them and now he's summoned them
here oh an army of pergil taking out all
the Imperial ships not sure if these
things are cute or Eldritch Horrors they
hold thrawn here as they grab the whole
ship Ezra's like yo guys sorry this was
the only way because Ezra's taking
thrawn off the board by warping him out
of here to who knows where no one's
quite sure what to do with this
development except of course Chopper who
takes the opportunity to blow up the
entire Imperial base and so our Rebels
have saved lothal and a short time later
Luke Skywalker blows up two death stars
and feeds the emperor so all around the
Galaxy the day is saved in the epilogue
we learned that Hera was pregnant yes
her and kanan's son Jason sindula but as
for Ezra he left them a message that he
wasn't gone for good they just need to
find him so Sabine wren's gonna take
point on finding him and she gets help
from Ahsoka Tano who's now come back as
Ahsoka the white and that's where Star
Wars Rebels comes to an end
if you like this recap hit that
subscribe button for more of the best
Recaps of TV and movies
[Music]